[muzyka]
[śmiech]
zaangażowany tylko w tę operację.
zawodowych oficerów i wykonawców
nie ma poborowych, a my nie
planujemy to zrobić teraz słyszymy
na co ustawić strefę zakazu lotów
terytorium na terytorium na terytorium
Ukraina
sprawić, że to niemożliwe
na terenie Ukrainy jest to możliwe tylko
z terytorium niektórych sąsiednich
państw, ale jakikolwiek ruch w tym
kierunek zostanie przez nas rozważony
jak udział w konflikcie zbrojnym
strony, z której terytorium
grozić naszym
personel wojskowy, będziemy w tej samej sekundzie
być traktowani jak członkowie wojska
konflikty i kolacja w każdym razie
członkowie są w stanie wojennym
wprowadzony w kraju zgodnie z prawem
dekretem Prezydenta i musi być
potwierdzona decyzją Rady Federacji w r
w przypadku agresji zewnętrznej, w tym
określone obszary dla
nie mamy takiej sytuacji
i mam nadzieję, że zagłada
[muzyka]
Chwała Ukrainie